go
I hate crazy
appointed I
hate you and how about you don't
encourage it hate is such a stress it
really is oh everybody starting off with
the hate Jordan Coleman let's just take
it back this is episode
156. welcome back to the corridor cast
who knows how much longer it'll be
called that but I hope you're having a
great day I've got Jordan Allen Jordan
Coleman which one is really named Jordan
and of course the wonderful the
enigmatic is that the right word
the enigmatic does it matter what does
enigmatic means I don't even know it
depends on the day yeah it depends on
how enigmatic it means difficult to
interpret or understand
um well maybe we can come up with a
better word for you
that makes sense because everyone does
think you're Matt so how how common
knowledge is that have we talked about
on the podcast at all no but I I love
how you're shifting now away from the
whole beans debate because I was about
to bring that up let's talk about let's
talk about it just uh shift away from
the beans today in Corridor okay on
screen identity Jake are you aware of
this situation that's arising uh wow
it's a problem the first time that it
happened I was driving us to go to
Vicky's quesadillas Matt saw a pair of
my heels and my Jeep he put on the heels
as you did yeah as one does and made it
into a crew cuts and someone commented
cute heels Nick a couple people I think
it wasn't yeah it wasn't the only
comment in in the list of comments that
that called Matt Nick and then we
started getting Nick being called Matt
in some circumstances and there seems to
be a lot of confusion around who's who
well it's very confusing to me too
because I've never been you know on
camera wearing high heels before on the
on the channel never been on camera
right I mean what I was saying is you
know I've never been you know seen on
camera yeah yeah it's an important thing
yeah
they're tall let me tell you yeah that's
right
um
okay something some wires you know some
some things made people think that that
was me for a second but why is that it's
a good question very curious well you
you are quite similar in terms of
hairiness hair hair quantity
yeah I feel like there's a bit of a
distinction but all right
well you do you both have you both
you're both about the same height are
you roughly we're close next time you
both have you both have curly black hair
yeah
cheers yeah you both have beards and
um yeah and they both they both you're
very very we both edit yeah we both we
both have probably taken photos doing
this before yeah oh you guys both yeah
oh we drink Lacroix we are Lacroix boys
yeah
we're scorpions as well so that's right
you're dual scorpions we are we are what
does that mean well they yeah go ahead
yeah that's right easy Rigs and goof off
on set is what it means but um yeah
and the lower thirds come up at the same
time it's understandable that people
don't know it's too quick yeah like
scorpion switch I think you know maybe
it's time for me to distinguish my look
a little bit more because I I don't want
to blame the audience for this like look
if if people aren't able to distinguish
is it Matt wearing high heels is it Nick
wearing high heels yeah it's on me yeah
so I'm thinking shave it all off get rid
of every single thing get rid of it you
know oh you guys are both hairy put a
stop to that whole canvas wax and just
see how it goes for a week I like it man
I can get you 65 off of laser hair
removal
unless you were to get pregnant then you
would get your hair the hair comes back
thank you for letting me know that okay
so I can get you 100 off waxing if you
let me do it
because I'll pay for it wow there you go
take that take that off
I thought see Nick I thought you were
you were making your distinction known
through your mustache I was trying but
apparently it's just fall fallen on
blind eyes yeah yeah all eyes go to the
heels apparently and then should we see
who walks better in heels
we've been talking about making a crew
cuts video kind of about this topic uh
you know let us know if that's something
you want to see I think you know trying
to find anyone's identity in a studio
full of filmmakers when one is a
filmmaker
how do you do that you know yeah and we
all have beards a lot of us are white
CIS males yep and a lot of us are you
know kind of similar Personalities in a
way so I can I can see I can see it I
feel like that's probably the origin of
why Jordan I get confused as well
totally yeah yeah you guys are so
similar yeah I always I confuse you
myself yeah yeah so it's you know we're
all kind of in a similar boat there I
think you know one way to do that like
to solve that issue would be just a
simple nickname
um you know something like that like
beans maybe yeah beans is an interesting
one because I don't think either of us
are really into it you know who came up
with that that was Griffin 100 because
he wanted knife as a nickname yeah this
whole thing is just because of Griffin
like he he had a little bit of an ego
about him he really wanted something he
never even got his own nickname I feel
like beans is probably more appropriate
for him for him right as the originator
but I don't feel like you guys are
deflecting pretty hard I think maybe we
should just give it to him I think he's
Jordan Jordan Allen I mean listen I
don't know if how much the the podcast
audience knows about the Lacroix
Revolution but
I don't think you know when that when
that went down
um you you became beans again and mine
oh yeah I forgot about it no but that's
yeah yeah so here's the thing for those
of you who don't know when I first got
here uh Jordan and I we needed to settle
it once and for all because people were
just throwing Jordan around and we were
both getting confused and wasn't my
decision a smash game ensued pretty sure
to decide who was going to be Jordan and
I won and Jake I feel like being a
lawyer yeah do you respect the law well
yes we respect the law but we also
believe in uh due process and a fair
trial
um and I'll be honest I don't think that
that was really a fair trial trial by
combat it's not fair well listen I mean
how long have you been playing smash
before that I don't see how that's
relevant uh it's incredibly relevant
how often do I play yeah how often does
Coleman play is that on me I mean could
you go into a court and like there's a
really established lawyer and someone
who's just cutting their teeth and they
get destroyed and like well it just
started no you wouldn't talk about the
you wouldn't talk about the performance
of the lawyer you would talk about
whether or not the person has a criminal
history that would certainly come into
play especially depending on the type of
crime I have a history yeah I'm playing
smashing and you have a history of
playing Smash and therefore would
probably be judged more critically you
know and given that there was no
handicap given to Coleman
uh and she was just expected to just be
tossed into the trial by cons
it's it's my legal opinion that that
that was not a um Fair Drive Fair trial
well here's here's the issue that I have
with with this judgment that's coming
down is you know there we consume a lot
of Lacroix in the studio some would say
too much yeah some would say too much
and those two were actually here right
now some would say Jake and Jordan yeah
and so what they did was they cut off
the Lacroix Supply to all of us who are
just working so hard to make our dreams
reality
you know just the the cold corporate day
and instituted what was it J and J's
Refreshments where you have to buy
Lacroix at a 300 markup
we weren't even able to Institute [ __ ]
because y'all came in behind everyone's
backs
let's just back it up let's give a
little
all right so so going into going into
about midway last year when everyone was
coming back into the studio and you know
it was like hey you know the the we said
we said hey let's let's get some Lacroix
as part of the you know the available
um
let's get some champagne for the boys
and and the Lacroix was bought and then
we and then it was drank very quickly
very quickly and then and then more was
bought and then that was drank very
quickly and then
it kind of became this thing where
people weren't even keeping track
of how many cans they were drinking a
day we were finding wounded soldiers
around it was costing that hurt me too
Jake I would say a a a a a a noteworthy
amount of money to provide these
Refreshments to everybody in studio you
know you're talking 15 15 plus people in
studio and in any given day and
everyone's drinking a few of those a day
you know that adds up
pretty quick yeah and so I I don't
so so Nico approached me
and he said hey what's what's going on
with these Lacroix and I said uh it
wasn't it Sam I mean people are drinking
them well see I'll get there and then
and then he's like I think we should I
think we should just you know pump the
brakes on on so much Lacroix it wasn't
even discussed how much or that we were
gonna ban it or whatever
and then it turns out that it wasn't
even Nico's idea it was Sam's idea wow
and Sam had said listen I come into the
studio
I want my Lacroix and I go to get it and
I I limit myself you know one two a day
sometimes if it's a long day and what
what's happening is I'm going to the
fridge there's no Lacroix in there and
then we're worse off even than that I'm
walking around and I'm finding wounded
soldier Lacroix it's not right all over
there you're actually upset about that
well and so it he just he just you know
was said listen I don't feel like people
are respecting it anymore and you know
it's it's it's people are consuming it
as they would just water for hydration
which which I I was one of those people
I was consuming Lacroix for hydration
I'll be honest because they're so
delicious I was there too sorry yeah and
and we all got a little carried away and
then the the issue wasn't even that we
were gonna ban it we were just not gonna
buy it for like a week or two
and then
all of a sudden the conversation came up
well hey maybe maybe there's a better
way we can do this right and this is
where this is where the paths began to
split Jordan Coleman and I the actual
Jordan in the studio oh wow okay came up
with a plan I see where we are business
partners though keep that in mind
business partners yeah well well listen
we're in production it's our job Jordan
I mean you know it's our job to come up
with Solutions and and to provide
solutions to the teams schedule things
have been labeled under the word
Solutions but yeah
I'm just saying let's look at the
history
do you think that I enjoyed this Jalen
Nick at the end yes I think there's like
a thousand percent chance there will be
a studio so we came up with an idea
to provide a ice cold solution to
people's Lacroix needs we we said hey
let's buy a fridge we'll buy a mini
fridge we'll stick it up there in the
main Studio three and anytime anybody
wants one they can purchase one for one
dollar and we will use the money that is
accumulated from selling Lacroix to
continue to buy more Lacroix and of
course we're selling them for a dollar
yeah do we make a little bit of money
yeah we make a little bit of money
what's wrong with capitalism and then
they got all upset and said no you're
gonna charge us all this money why can't
we have Lacroix we have and then it
became a rights issue
and then I mean and then what happened
Jordan why don't you inform us because
this this part of the history is a
little gray for me so why don't you go
ahead and
I'll tell you what happened fill in the
audience the people took control
the people took control you were part of
the people America was founded no it's
funny anytime somebody says the people
are taking control the person who's
saying that always has the most to gain
don't they well that was the beautiful
thing about our situation you see Fenner
yeah and Jonah let our little rebellion
in its early stages they brought in a
fridge they hid the fridge in the bowels
of the studio just way down in the
depths of the prop room and filled it to
bursting in the poop dungeon with fresh
ice cold Lacroix for the people at no
charge
there was no tally system there was no
padlock on the door it was come and go
please contribute to build a better
Society we would go we'd take Lacroix
we'd be smiling all the way down there
filling it up for our friends and our
family
to make a better future Jake is it
working so well it was working
beautifully that romantic how did you
feel the need to hide it though because
because if the people knew some people
knew um but yeah why did you hide it I
was no longer if Jake and beans found
out about the secret Lacroix then it
would not have gone well they would have
been confiscated and we would have had
to go to the bank why would we have why
would we have coffee yeah it wasn't
coming from my wallet which is the
corridor wallet why why are moonshine
operations hidden Jake what happens if
they get caught
they were made illegal yeah it's made
illegal we didn't sound familiar people
can because if you
if you purify alcohol and then sell it
to people and it's not done with a
license you do run the risk that you can
poison somebody and kill them so it's
not a perfect metaphor
he's saying in the context of this I'm
saying Mission yes you know that was
something that happened people needed
their the drinks what we had was pure
and it was special and it was a group of
people that was growing and we were
bringing people into the fold slowly we
were growing at a mature rate and we
knew that if we got caught
they would be banned the the one dollar
Lacroix would be back we would be
completely broke because we've never
even implemented the one dollar Road
Lacroix I know we were front running the
issue it's interesting it's interesting
I I like your romantic perspective on it
but let's get to the facts here okay
where
did the where did the money come from to
purchase the Lacroix right it came from
each individual who was involved right
yeah okay and if one person would have
abused that system what would have
happened to your perfect little romantic
system there we would have had a town
hall meeting
and we would have discussed it yeah
nothing you would have discussed it yeah
we see the beautiful thing the beautiful
would have happened if that person
wouldn't would have not listened
then it gets violent Jake but we don't
we don't have to go there because look
the reality is
through Evolution right humans have
stayed in small tribes when you're in a
small tribe you know everyone everyone
knows you you know what you're
contributing you know what they're
contributing community
we're all listen Jordan Coleman and I
have beans listen Jordan Coleman and I
are all about Community yes that's what
we're all about
we just also accept that people can be
selfish they can be abusive and take
advantage of other people I agree and
you know you bring in a few very very
basic Market factors and all of a sudden
voila they benefit everybody Jordan and
I were open to giving shares out of J
and J's Refreshments oh first
Refreshments interesting would have J
J's Refreshments would have made a
profit keeping Law and Order trickle
down when people purchase so that when
people purchase a Lacroix they then do
so as part of a transaction ensuring the
security of the provision for all right
and then we would have taken that and
anyone who wanted to be a part of it we
would have sold shares we would have
done that you were gonna go public huh
yeah this is the first ever it was gonna
be like Bitcoin oh wow that's okay
that's not exactly the same thing yeah
not exactly
um yeah but yeah that's what that's what
we're willing to do but see this is
never spoken to the people the people
were in the dark the people were scared
I was never given a chance
utopian society J and B's Refreshments
is selling Lacroix for dollar
everything's balanced but guess what
Society filled in the blanks yeah I
think you guys were a little rash I
think yeah I think you were a little
rash and jumping to the conclusion that
that all of a sudden these things were
banned when when exactly were they
specifically banned that's what I was
like walked in the room and it was like
no more the croissants yeah
I tried to make Lacroix from scratch but
Jake have you ever seen a man trying to
blow bubbles into a couple of years
so he was just so animalistic and angry
at the time he bit into a lime yeah
opened it up poured it into water and
then and then blew bubbles this really
happened this really happened he was in
a bag but people don't know how bad it
was here people were tearing each other
apart yeah it was awesome I think it
just goes to show that that's why we had
to take a step back on Lacroix because
you guys are I mean right I see a little
out of hand there wasn't I mean there
was abuse there was certainly a pulling
back that was required or at least maybe
we could have done like bread lines or
something the the Lacroix
we got our little disbursement of
Lacroix that's what I thought was gonna
be implemented
because who would be doing that I would
be doing that I don't want to do that
you get one Lacroix on Monday and you
have to make it
the thing that I love about all your
Solutions the orange flavors is that
there's just this assumption that
they'll just that the you know the bread
lines will just be there right who makes
who makes the bread lines possible you
need an organizing body to organize
those bread lines you need somehow that
organized body needs to have Law and
Order all I'm saying is that the
inherent Law and Order of Simply selling
a Lacroix for one dollar a piece and
giving out shares is already existent in
this very simple process called supply
and demand who will stop price gouging
the shareholders will ensure that that
price gouging doesn't happen because
they are also the purchasers but this is
an amendment to history because there
there was no talk of shares this is this
is just noise now noise from the
corporate machine and we don't need to
listen because the corporate machine
Revolution
still out there it is
and how is how is it going currently
because just so everyone knows just so
everyone knows so so so we discovered
the fridge okay it was in The Prop Room
it was covered it was hidden in plain
sight beautifully it was it was hiding
behind a cardboard box like Osama Bin
Laden hidden behind us okay it was very
Bin Laden and it was sitting there
and we brought it out in the open
and there was Blood Sweat and Tears and
then we decided that it would be open
for all and that we everyone said you
know it very quickly became this
ritualistic you need to say the same
thing as everyone else there was this
phrase going around I will contribute
more than I drink and everyone had to
say it I will contribute more than I
drink and those who didn't say it were
immediately suspected of wrongdoing just
so easy promises
no this isn't look the video is going to
come out yeah I didn't say it's gonna
come out and you will see the video
evidence that what I'm saying happened I
did I did say that oh I did I did say
that and the other people said it but
what that is is me saying I will be a
good person
and then if you don't want to say that
sentence that is inherently suspicious
because what happened was this is the
problem with these types of socialist
Endeavors Jordan and Ice beans beans
this is what I'm saying so anyways we
heard that how is it going I will say
this someone tried to sabotage someone
tried to sabotage La Revolution now that
this the fridge is just on display for
everyone even non-revolution members
someone drank or took all of them it was
a full fridge and someone took all of
them but do you know what we did the
next day
we filled it up
again we didn't burn anyone on the stake
we didn't do a man hunt we let it go
and to this day there was a steady flow
of Lacroix how many times you're gonna
let that slide how many times you're
gonna refill well that's how many times
you're going to do it because I know
you're having someone accountable I
don't drink LaCroix
do you stop saying that when are you
gonna hold people accountable answer
that well look we'll cross that bridge
when we get there right now we have a
beautiful Society we are and it sounds
like the for-profit machine wants in the
dude they see the demand and they're
like how can we how can we provide this
and make a buck off it look I'm sorry
you don't like the joy that is correct
I'm sorry you guys have such a flat
water it's like okay like sure let us
enjoy it though yeah you know I'm sorry
that you guys have such a uh jaded view
of what simple supply and demand
economics can provide to a community
um we're not saying we we want to just
gouge everybody and run off to the bank
laughing all the way home we're just
saying we want to provide something that
is inherent Law and Order and ensures
that everyone has an equal opportunity
to purchase a Lacroix that's all my
biggest nuts so bad my biggest issue
with it is that you know initially this
body is what brought Lacroix into this
ecosystem that didn't have it before and
we grew to love it and we grew attached
and only then was there a 180 degree
turn and a 300 price hike to continue
enjoying the life that you've addicted
so you think it was like a thing that
that court or digital like as a drug
dealer
to get you hooked on it he gave us those
free samples
here's how far I would be willing to go
to show you once you're once your little
communist experiment fails what I'm
willing to do is I'm willing to go in on
J J's Refreshments to no profit to
myself and to accept shareholders okay
okay
in order to prove to you that it wasn't
a conspiracy theory by quarter digital
to get everyone you know addicted and
and also that these simple mechanisms
that will be in place are will will be
actually really sturdy and and and
really last for a long time I believe
will Jordan make the same promise
to get you
yeah but for to no profit no I don't
need money
this is a beautiful conversation we're
having because it's so nice
this has a shareholder though so as a
shareholder with everyone else would I
shareholder all I hear is give me money
I think we should we should just divide
the price of a Lacroix sleeve but the
amount of cans yep and then pay that
much per can so that we break even pain
med assistant we pay for the Lacroix
drink what about the electricity what
about the person who goes and gets it
what about the person who makes sure
that it's stocked there's a lot of other
factors here you're not paying for
that's correct but in the old system the
one that you guys began none of that was
paid for anyway and that Lacroix was not
paid for so what we're doing is we're
meeting you in the middle court the
corporation is no longer part of it
J and J no no I'm saying yeah we need an
organization to divide up and make sure
that the shares are there and this
language Lacroix lives but I'm saying
court or digital is no longer paying for
it which is the whole problem that we
say yes
I think I think the system of paying for
the can for the for the street value of
the can is the way forward what might I
say I did get Lacroix for the fridge
last Monday the the community fridge
yeah what us what a gesture well what
did you think about this though Jordan
if somebody or beans sorry I mean we
still haven't come to terms
right there yeah
so if somebody's going out every week
purchasing cans bringing them to the
studio making sure that they're all
lined up by flavor ice cold ready to go
and ensuring that you know the cost is
distributed equally amongst the members
right we just create a simple membership
and it your cost is simply the cost to
operate that
that that privilege if you will would
the fridges be franchisable
um I like that that's something that I'd
be interested in pursuing you know when
I hear franchise I hear just give me
money that's what I well here's the
here's the situation the fridge I'm
trying to do something I'm trying to do
something that's non-profit yeah I hear
you the fridge itself was actually paid
and provided by Fenner on behalf of the
and who's paying for the electricity
well that's the thing is that's that's
your half right so the fridge has been
paid for the cooling device the multi
hundred dollar instrument was that a
multi 100 how long would it take back to
the person who paid for it in the form
of electricity
so Jordan and I Jordan Coleman and I
were offering a solution that would pay
for that back to the person who provided
it and cover the cost of electricity and
give money back to shareholders and at
least break even I think it's something
we can bring to perhaps a Roundtable
discussion at the head of next week I
can speak with the people on our meeting
of the leadership because they were
speak with the leadership of the party
that would be cool well that's the
beauty of it the leadership is just
everyone in the uh in the DMS though is
it though we're all leaders of this
group Jake we all speak freely and
listen everyone knows there's like
psychological evidence that once you get
more than like six or eight people in a
room like they immediately divide into
like hierarchy that's just the way that
it is
you did have the limoncello party and
then he had the lemon party yeah all
right yeah and yes tensions did Flair
but
there is a resolution I hate to do this
here I am actually Plum Bloom I'm so
sorry sorry I didn't mean to put you on
the spot with that but I am Plum Bloom
party can we I'm sorry let's talk about
beans
yeah I'm just gonna get angry if we keep
talking about this yeah we need to move
on and beans I feel like what is a beans
right we that's what we need to identify
I feel like I almost feel like this is
like choosing whose beans right yeah
that's too easy that's too easy it's
much more motivating to have beans be a
crown of
shitly beans
energy and you do something that's kind
of beansy yeah then you're being a vegan
we're acting real beanie right now
beanie you know beansy
being called Bean is so much more
offensive Bean like I'd rather be plural
yeah shut up Bane yeah like that just
hurts my feelings I like that I think
you're being a bit beans right now it's
that's a good deterrent to your typical
and if there's more than one being a
bean then you're a string bean oh if you
guys are like because it's multiple yeah
I see what you did a string of beans I'm
not mad at that I think that's a nice I
think we've come to ahead on a couple of
things that that have been we didn't
really get far Brewing well I I was glad
I'm glad to have this discussion yeah I
feel bad party I hope that party
leadership comes back with uh a
reasonable solution though I know it
would detriment their specific position
in all of this which you know control
which is the thing that we're trying to
avoid isn't it trying to avoid people's
personal gain here isn't that what we're
trying to avoid I would agree and I
think that you know being reasonable is
kind of in our nature
um as we've proven through so far I
think the fridge in the basement you
know Jake I I feel like hiding a fridge
in the basement and then
hiding is a strong word immediately to
the conclusion that we were going to be
without Lacroix forever
I think I think that what we what we did
is better to be prepared it's better to
be prepared and what we did it reflected
the heart of America
yeah the rebellious Spirit the
independent nature that we'll do it for
ourselves we don't need it's true that I
am British it's true that I was born in
the UK
but look I'm going for citizenship so I
really need to kind of show
show the American Spirit yeah and then
and then there's the other leader of
your party another leader of your
parties from Canada so I'm confused at
like what you guys are trying to look if
I was if I was on on Boston Harbor I
would have probably pushed over some tea
maybe I don't know
try going to The Frigid Lake of Boston
and pushing tea into that yeah well it's
not like I might have done it it's an
ocean it's an ocean but what we're
showing is that America really is built
upon and founded by immigrants you know
Fenner is an immigrant I am an immigrant
and we are showing the American Spirit
by building something for ourselves and
I thought I was hoping that that might
be more respected by you Jake
you know that's a great spin on it I
like that and you know I think that if
if see there's there's a couple things
about the whole the whole immigrant
thing right it's it's bringing bring the
spirit bring the spirit of ambition
right and bring bring the ability to
adapt and survive and go and be
rebellious that yes 100 right but
there's also a thing called assimilation
right and and also it's it's part of
becoming as much as you're becoming part
of America America is becoming a part of
you right and and one thing that that we
do here is we use basic market economics
to keep Law and Order in so many
different forms and have been doing it
for hundreds of years you know and
really
that's something that I I don't feel
like you're considering right now but I
do admire your your grit and your
rebellious nature that is admirable and
I do appreciate it I will say that yeah
so if you really want to be accepted
here what he's saying is maybe you know
maybe do pay for the workplace yeah you
gotta do things legally you know on on
paper so things don't come back to haunt
yet well trade is not illegal this was
open trade no no it was a secret
it was a secret it was a secret a secret
trade illegal of of legal goods and
nothing is more American than also on
the street or inside of a house is it
still legal interesting you call it
crack
it's a legal commodity but we can agree
look we'll handle this in the meeting I
want all of our brothers and sisters
there will unite as one and we will have
that discussion okay but I think there's
a way forward
well I'm hoping you'll stop
I don't know our web we don't know our
Network you don't know if we go
trust me we have people everywhere so as
you as you can see probably by this
point
um this is very serious topic for us uh
it's been hotly debated
um and uh somehow it seems to touch upon
some other
more deeper
um aspects of our society and and so
hopefully Daniel can capture that in a
Crewcuts episode with crew cut season
three because
um yeah a lot of raw emotion it was
quite going in quite emotional morning
that morning
um oh I'm actually going through all the
footage right now I asked Jonah I said
is there anything because I I got a da
Vinci license so I can just hone in and
like learn it but I wanted something to
actively try to do I was like Jonah what
do you have for me he goes well I have a
Lacroix story and man is this just
hilarious re-watching you guys find out
that I didn't get Lacroix that Monday oh
man and you trying to make your own with
a straw and that was rough I love yeah
that's like saying yeah like the
suffering of people is hilarious but
yeah whatever
funny Howard you're also now you know
editing the footage
fake news over here look guys this whole
podcast is US airing out our dirty
laundry so like apologies but you're
also getting you're getting really uh
clued into what's been going on around
here and you know what apparently
there's some stuff you know what's the
most concerning part of all is that at
no point in this whole process did we
ask what Socrates would do we that's
true yes that's our holy sag oh I know
you're playing around that's the one
thing that's the one thing in this
office more that has more emotion tied
into it the holy sack than anything else
someone played a prank at the end of
Friday where they put a replica of the
Holy sack already sacrilegious might I
just say underneath where the sack rests
and every single one of us that came in
saw it on the ground and had a mini
panic attack
it was a disgusting act who did that was
it Market I think it was Daniel I think
the fact that he wasn't even there to
enjoy it he was gone so he did that just
because it disgusted that thing finally
does fall it's gonna I think the studio
might fall I'm that's why he doesn't
know about this uh you were throwing
around these rubber balls uh one day and
one of them got stuck to the ceiling and
and that was that was literally like
three or four months ago yes this is
crazy because because we had a bunch of
these little squishy balls and they're
not sticky by Nature they're really not
they would get occasionally less balls
stressful yeah they'd get like they'd
leave a little residue of like slight
slight stickiness if you squeeze them
too long too too much you know but this
one in particular we threw up onto the
roof and it stuck and we have tried to
replicate with a plethora of additional
balls nothing has even come close the
longest one lasted that was sticky by
Nature lasted one hour and we are four
months deep in this holy moment also
it's been the hottest season here in L.A
and I swear to god dude around my
apartment anything sticky yes just
unsticks when it gets hot yeah it's just
like like random [ __ ] will just go
whoosh and fall into the floor I'm like
oh God no I stuck that up in your
apartment that's sticky so I had sticky
blinds like blackout curtains that I
stuck onto the thing
for something no I mean it's industrial
grade adhesive that like peels off paint
if you take it off so glue yeah it's
cool
that fell I've had a curtain rod Nick
yeah very simple but my gosh can't get
them at you can get them at Ross for
like five dollars
my dash cam that is is designed to stick
through all sorts of weather fails on
almost a daily basis in this heat and
the holy sack Remains Not designed to
stick designed to bless cottage cheese
ceilings like plaster on the ceiling is
not popcorn popcorn but there's nothing
sharp there to stick to it couldn't have
punctured there's no there's no
explanation in physics that could
explain it's not a popcorn ceiling it's
like uh it's a textured seal textured
like plaster right yeah it's a textured
plaster not popcorn but the next thing
the next level away from popcorn towards
flat but not definitely not flat it's
textured but uh but yeah this is It's
become a very big deal around here and
uh and is the only thing that I think
currently you know people feel stronger
about than this Lacroix debate that's
how serious the Lacroix is you had to
choose between the sack and the sack
this is not up for debate the sack is
life so did you write the 10 sack
Commandments no that was sent in yeah
yes and we mounted it it belonged it
belongs who sent in the 10 second
commandments
I can't remember right now but I can
look it up but yeah they sent that in
and I was like we will Mount this we
will Mount this it will be known things
are getting so scary around here it's
getting culty I don't really understand
it's like Progressive like every time I
look away there's a new like weird clap
chance thing I think the chance the
chance have been off like off the rails
recently yeah we've been doing a bit too
much of that I think we should maybe
maybe we dial it down a little bit but
the religion stays probably well we'll
dial the rest back but the sack
religion yeah maybe don't use that
specific word you know yeah it's like
really stupid
you just use that foreign
a choice to acknowledge
bro welcome to the show welcome to your
choice to be here it's like a game show
foreign
[Laughter]
it's a game show and it's hosted by you
in white robes and and and what it is is
each level it's like Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire but each level there's two
choices and as you pick through the
levels you only have one choice to make
per round and as you pick through you
don't know if the next round is gonna be
two things you don't want
you know or like one of them is going to
be a bad thing like saddle you with ten
thousand dollars of credit card debt you
know like something something like that
and then eventually yeah the choice
that's what we'll call it I like that
but if you but if you choose the sack if
you choose what the sack would want it
always leads you to the promised land
yeah All Is Forgiven all that debt
all that Lacroix did I like it man I'm
into it yeah it's and it's crazy too
because you know Dean uh our our
in-house skeptic
[Laughter]
he doubted he doubted the miracle and so
we decided to shoot the SAG this was a
disgusting I'm still upset that we did
this Dean tried to to to get it off yeah
he said he said it won't stand if it's
shot he says it will fall yeah if it
does if it doesn't fall you can shoot me
in my sack yeah and the sacrifice sure
what happened
well yeah so so he he doubted it and he
put his sack on the line and I do
respect that but again shouldn't have
been Downing in the first place and sure
enough Matt lined up a shot and shot it
with this really strong propulsion Nerf
gun it made one heck of an impact but
the sack stood it makes no sense we all
freaked out and we shot Dean in the sack
and yeah and now he's a he's a Believer
and that's a beautiful thing but we're
not doing that anymore after you know
the week after that he was stricken by a
sickness interesting yeah I'm not saying
it's related but you know you could but
hey but it could be but it could be um
yeah but he shot it didn't he
you know so think about that yeah I know
I know the more you think about it the
worse it gets
seriously I think about a lot yeah so
there's a lot there's a lot to uh look
forward to in crew cut season three
um these are just two
too little insights into some of the
things that'll be that'll be coming out
but um not normal around here you never
know right you never really know yes I
do see everything and every cult leader
thinks that they're doing the right
thing
Jared Leto you know
it's a dangerous Parts
I don't know whatever
it is a danger we're on a dangerous path
here but I'm gonna keep walking it
because I want to see how long it is
but we probably should start dialing it
back
I don't know just as long as
yeah we did we did sacrifice the hand of
a stuffed animal that was that was God
I'm not one to talk yeah you were part
of that yeah Nick you were all and I was
like straight out of the gate I'd never
participated
James really wanted to be a part of it
it's just a sick excuse to sacrifice
things I just felt the energy I needed
to be a part of it I mean dude that
LaFontaine thrower had been sitting
there on the table
if anyone doesn't know it's this is Luke
law fentane branded freaking Bowie knife
I don't know
yeah
well I I put one next to my desk yeah
and now every time someone walks by they
come they'd mess with it they twirl it
you're in an office full of dudes if you
put a big throwing knife on your desk
and then there's also a religious
ceremony going on yeah we need to get
the internet back and there's also a
stuffed animal yep with two perfectly
good hands yeah with I mean it only
needs one realistically I mean call me
Pagan but right but a sacrifice was
required it was required and also you
know like this is also a call to anyone
out there who has other good sack puns
because we're always looking for more I
feel like we've really scraped the
bottom of the barrel at this point but
I'm just eager for more Minds on this so
please leave them in the comments like
oh man man oh man yeah that is
interesting I'll be interested to see
how this fall goes I don't know if we're
gonna make it to the end of the year at
this pace yeah um you know oh no
nick no
see because you were bad-mouthing the
sack yeah you did say one thing back
all over himself it's totally related
that's crazy
um here wow Nick Nick was bad nothing
this Nick was bad-mouthing the sack and
he spilled water all over himself dude
it's so great
oh my God I'm so sorry for the person
who sent me so what what are you guys on
the topic of the Fall what are you guys
looking forward to this fall like let's
let's be real for a second
Lacroix and the sack or you know is
there is there more to life than that
pumpkin spice
there's a there's a bit more to life
pumpkin spice
um yeah are you talking as far as
projects are concerned or just anything
in general I think to be honest I'm
really excited about this uh this rated
G video that we're doing yeah I'm like
very very excited about that yes so
we've been called upon by you know as
you're so uh as you so affinitively put
them the people Jordan Allen to do a
G-rated
version of our rated R things and we
finally I think we finally have the
title yeah we can share it yeah oh share
it please oh my gosh it's saw rated G
it's gonna be the bet I'm just we're so
excited all the possibilities because
the Saw movies are repulsive if you
haven't seen them the deaths in those
movies are just so off-putting and the
fact that people thought of that stuff
as well to me
um we should bring him in for a
sacrifice for sacrifices at some point
but we like the the fun of taking
something that is so just Baseline
horrific and making it rated G is such a
fun Challenge and like go ahead question
in the back are you guys going to like
reshoot these scenes are you gonna just
take out this yeah this is gonna be all
like Sim CG comp stuff and how do you if
it already exists
well yeah one of the ideas for example
is like uh you know this this girls has
to like navigate through all these
needles that have been used I guess
which is already disgusting to find a
key and we're like what is rated G in
the sense that it still is torture but
is is kid friendly well a haystack well
what no what is what is literally the
most horrific thing that has to do with
kids that could hurt you the most there
is a right answer to this
stepping on Legos okay horrific right so
the idea of like replacing all these
needles with just loose Lego pieces they
have to navigate through or you know uh
oh man horrible you keep stepping on
them
so your little feathers tickling your
toes yeah like like tickle torture or
there's there's yeah there's all sorts
of fun ideas that we're playing with
right now but I think just just
executing that okay it will be will be
very fun we've never done something
rated G and everyone always asks us and
it's like
when we think about it it's like okay
Deadpool rated G that's not really going
to be that funny in the end because it's
just gonna be like maybe a guy flipping
around oh yeah but right yeah like that
was perfect because it sounds perfect
they're really perfect for Halloween yes
exactly yeah yeah and then in these crew
meetings guys I'm just catching up here
um yeah no we have a lot of really fun
actually Crew videos coming up that I'm
excited for a couple of them are
Halloween related also we have uh well I
noticed you guys were walking around and
there were some definitely some traumas
under the surface you know like right oh
my gosh I can't wait behind your eyes
like you know there would be a smile but
back but it's hiding the truth so smile
to hide the hurt yeah it's fine Peter
noticed too and he was like dude I think
I can figure out what these guys worst
nightmares are and I'll make those
nightmares in VR
members can get over their fears because
you have to face your fear to conquer it
people helping people dude people
helping people using technology to make
the workforce happier yeah make quarter
crew happier
so so we won't you know question the
sack and right yeah thank you get so
many videos done and and we're gonna
Force everyone to face their nightmare
fears force them to do it and of course
and of course that's yeah they'll have
to do it and then they'll have to face
them and then everyone will come out the
other side we'll come out the other side
better off
it's yeah the idea of a VR based
exposure therapy is so great I just I
can't wait I mean I can't wait let's see
what happens so I'm excited for that one
and then Ren's cooking up a little
classic Wren 360 video yeah
um very like kind of 2016 to 19 quarter
crew Vibes that thing is scary by the
way Jake
it goes at the speed of I don't know
fast dude yeah it does go that speed
it's uh what did he like took an air off
and it was just like the round part and
it left like an inch hole Yeah inside of
that bag what was it yeah it's a
crossbow it's crazy it's a compound
crossbow right yeah it's meant to take
out large game so I was surprised how
accurate it is oh dude
it is pinpoint accuracy you can get that
I mean crossbows are more accurate than
um compound bows but also you can get
compound bows if you have the right
technique you can get them incredibly
accurate at long distances
um like you know I'm talking 50 60 even
70 yards talking about you know hitting
something that's the size of what say
like a paper plate
that's crazy yeah well yeah because what
I'm saying it shoots like 700 yards yeah
something like that and I said 70. we're
hoping for like 200 once we get the
camera on yeah yeah that weight would be
you know obviously I don't know if I
don't know if it'll shoot that far with
a camera on it yeah we'll we'll see
that's gonna be part of the process here
but yeah it was pretty cool like going
to the like I guess the biggest archery
store in La and I would walk in it's
just like oh dude
I want to get a bow now yeah like this
is cool they're super fun I got one this
summer and I've been and I've been
shooting with it in my yard and it's
it's great man and it's very therapeutic
I go out there in the evening when like
the Sun is setting and I just you know
put 10 15 rounds so arrows through and
let's just kind of reset and move on
with your life yeah I have a bow up in
Washington at my parents place because
they actually haven't to shoot it and me
and my brother will do the same thing
we'll just go out and just shoot some
arrows it's yeah it's really good you
have to kind of Zen out for a little bit
yeah we can go shoot arrows oh that
would be super fun it's so weird I I've
been obsessed with not obsessed but
shooting arrows has always been like
super duper fascinating to me but it's
always felt like an inaccessible Hobby
and I genuinely hearing you guys say I
just go in the backyard and shoot it
yeah what am I it's always felt
inaccessible to me like I I can't
legally do that in the backyard no if
you have if you have uh I mean all you
need is like 20 yards
and a boat like a hallway yeah
like people and every yeah end of their
end of this how stress levels you're up
don't walk out your door
sorry guys
we used to do that in that yeah we shot
node videos we would we would shoot
arrows in there all the time yeah man we
would shoot him in studio three
yep oh my gosh and it was like this the
smash the 2015 equivalent to the smash
break was the arrow
Nico was telling me yeah you guys have
the indoor uh Archery sets yeah how we
can do this can we bring this back I
would totally bring that back me versus
not inside the studio with compounds
it'd be too much too much power but with
just a basic recurve inside the studio
it's the perfect uh distance for that
no way oh yeah I saw him grabbing his
arrows
it does feel good actually I was back in
the studio it's hilarious yeah yeah and
to hear that sweat yeah you know wow
yeah yeah dude it makes you it makes you
feel real good when that Arrow flaps
onto the Target right there that's
nessa's costume oh you're right yeah
there's you're you're right though
there's so many fun videos coming up
that are just all such a hoot to do so
many
um what else what else do we got cooking
up well we've got we've got the uh
accident manvi FX oh yeah one that was
cool that's we're gonna talk about that
too
sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that has an interesting
story
um Nico can speak more articulately to
the particulars of it but we were asked
to do a single effect for uh the
accident Man 2 movie with Scott Atkins
which drops next weekend
um so we're gonna release the video
where we did the effect but then this
interesting thing happened where the
person involved in the the person that
was on camera
[Music]
I'm not saying a name
cool can I not very good I'm just
oh yeah you're good Christian says
you're good
okay so anyway yeah that person was
convicted of a heinous crime and they
they were like hey guys uh we gotta
figure this out because you know this
person's in the movie and we don't know
what to do because we didn't obviously
see this coming
so the thing was kind of put on ice for
a while while they figured it out and
then they got they got all that squared
away and you know and they said okay
this is good to go you guys can can
um put this out there but
so it's just an interesting insight into
working on something that was like you
know sort of a privilege to work on and
Jordan obviously you we worked on it
Hands-On but it was an interesting
insight into having the privilege to
work on something uh and then also
seeing you know like hey in the real in
the real world and things you know
sometimes you get hit from out of left
field with something and that was very
bad that's how it goes but the effect
itself
that you did
for that is so cool shot and like the
way that it came together is just so
it's so good yeah and it's uh it's a Sim
that I've never done before and the idea
of it was I mean basically the the
concept is that it's wait can I I'm for
sure I'm good to talk about this yeah
okay I just want to be super safe there
but yeah I mean the idea is that the
skewer goes through the back of a head
and like and pushes out an eyeball yeah
and it's such a cool concept of like
something that you can do with visual
effects and like the minute that Nico
mentioned that that shot was like one of
the ones that we were gonna tackle for
this film
uh I was just crossing my fingers that
he'd look in my direction thankfully he
did so it's like a fire that's a fun
exploration into into that side of
things so that's a really fun video and
obviously we've got yours coming up Jake
uh Spiderman yeah oh yeah
this will come out Monday so that video
so sorry if you haven't seen it already
we're doing a video we did a video
where uh I saw it to do the Toby Maguire
Spider-Man tray catch where he catches
Mary Jane and then he catches all the
items on the tray in the lunchroom
high school we sought to do that shot in
camera verbatim to the way that they
shot it in the film and apparently it
took the film 156 takes
do you want to say how many attackers
I don't want to say how many it took I
want you to go watch it yeah because it
was fun and it it it was it was a blast
and when we when we did finally get it
yeah oh man yeah it was a high for me
but yeah yeah and we're just high in
general
[Laughter]
right I have never felt more beautiful
really fun though I felt stunning yeah
yeah I felt like oh that's how we decide
who gets beans who looks better in that
wig well that's that feels just like the
freaking Smash Brothers set up like I'm
gonna dominate that one okay so we
should probably find something else
you look at my hairline and tell me you
look better look at my hairline in that
wig and you tell me no that video was
fun because it was such a real
collaborative effort like with everyone
Jake had to be on point and then all of
us dropping dropping everything
everybody had to be
it was yeah everyone had a job to do
it was great
going how to walk like a woman how'd it
do yes
yeah
it's kind of hard to do that when you're
not alone
yep
[Laughter]
very Scottish Roots yeah it's just so
much good stuff yeah so is a good time
and uh yeah I'm super excited for
all these little videos and
all the little bits and pieces of ideas
now starting to get life again after the
son of a dungeon takeover and the punch
for punch takeover of our entire studio
for a year yeah now we can start to
breathe a little bit of life back into
some of these ideas I'm writing wizard
cops along with along with yeah Nico and
Sam and I had another riding session
today and uh
starting to it's starting to land on
paper now it's starting to come together
is that an episodic or is that yeah
right I know yeah it'll probably be
multiple episodes but we're gonna take
them one episode at a time yeah
um and and because it is non-narrative
it's just situational comedy
so each one kind of has like a theme you
know and there's sort of like little
tie-ins between like what they do in one
scene to what they do in the next but
it's not like a narrative where you need
to drop it all at once so we just kind
of want to continually write it and work
on it and deliver it until we feel like
it's
it's out there you know yeah that's
better I don't think the idea of like
spending a SP specific chunk of time to
just go okay let's do five episodes and
then drop these five and then we'll move
on to these other projects I think it's
just always going to be something that's
going
and we'll just continue because it's so
accessible in terms of how you shoot it
right so accessible you just need a
little bit of production some wardrobe a
cop car
two cameras with lights mounted on them
yeah and a couple beards and lobs even
and that's it
yeah because sod being done is gonna be
a crazy shift for sure how many shots do
you have to do with all that time where
yeah we're on we're on episode nine
right now which is the last episode oh
you're on episode nine yeah so we don't
have any notes on eight just yet
um but we're at the point now where
there's only one shot left on eight that
we need to do some work on but we're
pushing into nine now and just trying to
get like as far ahead as humanly
possible before any events come down but
I think when that show's done and yeah
like punch for punch being done having
the whole team accessible to like work
as a single unit to create things faster
is going to be so fun I'm really looking
forward to that for sure and I you know
I do Wonder like on the website with the
green lighting I know we've talked about
this a little bit but like smaller scale
single conceptual ideas like being put
up for for green lighting might be kind
of nice
um obviously with the massive
undertaking of you know like local zero
and yeah son of a dungeon yeah I think
that's that's what we're gonna do we're
already finalizing some of the for we
want to do like runoff style green light
ideas where yeah it's like hey this is
an idea this is an idea they're one-off
videos whichever one gets the most
points will make and then you know you
sort of have a bin of things that go
head to head it just makes it more
interactive there's more out of an
immediate
gratification too to it and it's great
to do the long form stuff too but when
they're all things that take a year you
know it's it's like
seeing the other side of what you put
your points into
we don't want it to feel like you're
waiting the whole time we want to have a
balance of both so that's something
that's definitely on the list to spin up
as we get into the end of the year yeah
no good things though all very exciting
stuff
yes sir
um all right well listen uh I don't know
if we solved all the problems here about
the Lacroix but we'll come back to it
yeah I feel I feel
it feels totally good to talk
about where this can go I'm still clear
on like where the bean scale is like
resting right I think right now it's a
crowd of Shame it's a crowd of Shame
yeah I hope Jake that that I somewhat
eloquently described our position and
that you no longer see me as beans
perhaps you might support creating a
beans crown that can be transitioned
between Jordan and I well 3D print one
okay yeah and perhaps we we might have
to earn that you know you know what you
might you might have moved up from Beans
to jeans
that is a huge step North
anything is really a huge man jeans Jake
I've been wearing jeans for like five
years you don't give me the name jeans
no your name doesn't start with a j yeah
but I wear the never mind she's another
jeans get anymore sorry pal you never
noticed on my jeans Jake you don't you
you wear these you wear those like khaki
like the things you're wearing right now
those aren't even are those jeans you
barely qualify as jeans they're more
like no no
I know that jeans aren't on the [ __ ]
menu those are like
oh man
thank you for joining us everybody we
hope you enjoyed this podcast we hope
you're having a great day and uh looking
forward to all the things that we're
gonna make here and and put out there
this fall so uh
[Music]
it's really nice of people to listen to
our ramblings for an hour that was legit
a ramble yeah we're just like in the old
phone
folks pray to the sand Grandpa shut up
are they talking about oh again Sac puns
in the comments guys please please
I will use all of them I'm trying to
think of some right now it's hard right
we've really kind of yeah
this is where you Fade Out Christian
devastating devastating to get us out of
here get us out of here bye